well let's let's let's talk a little bit
about this uh this is the story from npr
shinzo abe killed at 67 leaves a storied
legacy as japan's longest serving
premiere so for those that didn't see
the story i mean this is this it's been
a crazy week right i know the large
hadron collider just fired up but man
already yeah crazy as soon as that thing
opened and i mean it's honestly it's
been a crazy past month or so but so
shinzo abe in japan he's the longest
serving pro prime minister he's very
popular and he was shot in the back
cowardly cowardly assassination the dude
had a homemade shotgun
so
you know people talk about how he
opposed china
he was conservative he opposed communism
and so many are wondering what was the
motivation for taking him out could it
be that japan was leading uh leading the
cause against china in the in southeast
asia
you look at what joe biden's uh doing
with his son
joe biden
was taken oil out of the strategic
reserve and about a million barrels were
given to china through a company called
um uh what is it do you remember what
it's called
no i don't know no no no unit units
unesco unesco no no no not unesco
sonapec or whatever i can't remember the
name no i can't sorry we could we could
pull it up but um
you have to wonder you know his sons
involved in these companies had
apparently invested some something to
private equity
it really does look like
they're trying to give or hoard wealth
and bring it to china
you look at what happens in shinzo abe i
think
they're not going to win
when when these actions are overt and in
the public and it's no longer a
conspiracy theory it looks like the
liberal world order the
global agenda is failing they are
desperately trying to stop the holes
they're bursting in the hole but they
can't do it do you think that the people
like the the global banking
establishment for instance like the bank
for international settlements in
switzerland is it intentionally
moving the wealth and power away from
the liberal world order world order i
gotta get this right liberal world order
into bricks the chinese world order
and it's intentional and that's why
they're happy to see all this hatred of
the liberal world order
but they're still using the american
government as pawns to try and act like
we're defending it um
well that's a good point i mean
this
unipack unipack was that was a chinese
company
and it was associated with um signup
pack because the is the parent company
of which hunter biden uh is tied to
in 2015 a private equity firm he
co-founded bought a 1.7 billion dollar
stake in sign effect marketing
so i just think joe biden's gutting and
selling out the system and i think a lot
of it is they're trying i think they're
trying to transfer wealth to china who
invested you said that transfer wealth
to china biden's son invested in sign a
pack
hunter biden is tied to sound effect how
a private equity firm he co-founded
which bought 1.7 billion dollar 1.7
billion dollar stake and sign up okay
the the president's son is investing in
china in the communist chinese
oil companies that's freakish joe
his company is doing it and joe biden
took our oil and sent it their way oh
look we're not enemies at every turn i
get that but like at some point
like put the cards on the table
well well when you sit
when you sit in a position of power
um
it gives you opportunity
to make uh a fortune for yourselves
and i think that you know especially
when you use these terms like liberal
world order these people don't have an
allegiance to
america or united states per se right
they have an allegiance to their club to
their families all right we weren't
invited out to uh what's the club that
they just went out to out there in
switzerland davos davos we want to
invite the davos right so
i think it's that club and then when we
start saying like you know moving money
into china it could be a little bit of
hedging their bets right like you put a
little bit of money here i think they're
trying to invest in ukraine right and
they're just trying to hedge their bets
my thing is
especially when i've been studying uh
russian history which is quite
fascinating
um
they they
it seems like russia is the one place
they just can't penetrate too deeply
this world order and they've been poking
at it for a long time obviously going
back to uh the russian revolution et
cetera et cetera been poking at this
bear you know uh and then you know the
north was uh allied you know abe lincoln
basically owes russia for helping him
win that war the civil war
so you know um
i don't know man i i look at russia as
being a key uh
component in all of this
so when i look at this table right this
pseudo table you know i guess there's
america sitting at the table and there's
some chinese man sitting the table and i
think the russian russian oligarchs were
kicked out the club i guess right
and they're just not allowed at the
table anymore but i think russia has
always been its own thing and i think
that's the one thing they're trying to
conquer but i think there's somebody
buddy with china oh absolutely because
china is so
the population
they've come so far in in just a short
amount of time this is a backwards
agrarian society at one point like they
were all farmers and they started
producing shoes and they became a
superpower and bootleg and everything
and they got a strong military and
i think we we fear them i think there's
some legitimate fear there i think
everything we're seeing the board is
just the liberal world order has fallen
they've lost control they lost control
what is this liberal world order
it's a collection of um international
interests political leaders and
corporations
that are working together to prevent
world war three that's uh to the council
yeah well through is that their excuse
or is that what they're really trying to
henry kissinger talked a lot about
limited war and the idea was we would
set up proxy wars rather than say that
there's some russian aggression
communism
rather than bomb moscow we just have war
with them in vietnam yeah we could blow
up all our weapons and then you know
raytheon can make a crapload of money
yes still and we can we can keep the
power
moving the bombs building but without
having to destroy each other
oh that makes sense okay yeah yeah you
can you can pull up the council on
foreign relations and they break down
what is the liberal world order or the
liberal economic world order so when
george w bush or um
anyone else says a new world order
they're talking about something evolving
from the liberal world order something
else
the funny thing is there's a conspiracy
theory 10 years ago right and now it's
just public information yeah it's kind
of how binding's advisors going on tv
and saying it yeah that's why i think
it's falling apart they needed to rule
from the shadows call you crazy if you
criticize them they can't anymore now
it's just the
the truth i think the new world order
that they're trying to do is i don't
know if it's the metaverse if it's like
klaus schwab's world economic forums
that the governments cannot control
themselves they need corporations to
control them
they need the cooperation corporation
and he's wearing his like but sith
outfit have you seen that that cloaky
wears that's a new world order that
could be established but i don't like
the idea of people being like digital
slaves um getting their body heat
harvested and oh yeah
as long as you're in charge you know
like one of the five people controlling
big tech silicon valley everyone else
you're screwed yeah why are we talking
about it like the world order that takes
power next is the last one
i mean we've had many world orders right
many dynasties empires nope just one
which one is that just one just just i
don't know biden
just biden
just buy just globo homo
buy biden has been
the uh uh the the in charge of it all
since uh forever actually since atlantis
this is
actually satan
the biden family is you know what's
funny is like sun tzu when you are
strong appear weak when you're weak
appears strong like the gag is that joe
biden goes up on stage and then says
nonsense and reads the prompter and then
he's like bernie as soon as he gets
backstage he stiffens up straightens up
says all right get to work ladies you
know everybody he's like clean fast
sharp with it
it's like he's the 80th generation of
biden's who've been controlling the
world of andy kaufman is alive and well
ladies and gentlemen
obama you know criticizes him and then
behind the scenes he's like joe i'm so
you know i had to say that because
okay you get it whatever you need sir i
feel like it's the roman world order was
pretty predominant and then they made
the catholic church to kind of they're
like well if we can't govern them with
our with our emperor anymore we're going
to govern their minds with our religion
and well
dear yeah i i would agree with that um i
just want to add to that
i i think it's sort of reverse border i
think
people were first ruled by religion
and then
uh later on it was uh i guess
nationality yes when was that
when what like when nation states came
to be well you had the islamic world
right the islamic world was a huge
superpower and that's ancient as well i
mean they kind of in a way
well it depends on what you would define
as ancient i mean
50 years old
it's 50 years old yeah if you would say
50 years old then yeah like you know but
all the people like the ottoman empire
for example like ottoman empire doesn't
fall until i guess what is the late
1800s early 1900s yeah after world war
one yeah so the ottoman empire is like
hugely islamic et cetera et cetera so
they had a lot of power in fact the
you know if you read this book by
chancellor william called destruction of
african civilization uh there's uh if
i'm not misquoting him but there's a
part in there that basically says islam
is the reason why african civilizations
fell
uh and it's pretty interesting what his
theory is on that i can explain if you
want but yeah you have an elevator
version elevator pitcher yeah yeah
basically what he says is um
uh the the the missionaries of the
caliphate
sit on your borders and they basically
peddle the religion but the the people
that are sitting on the borders your
nation are also doubling as spies and
learning about your culture and your
ways and so on so forth how things move
and then basically what happens is
um
you know african is pit against african
because you're now choosing am i african
or my islam first and many people were
choosing islam over being african so now
you have this divided nation and it is a
lot of evidence to support it in the
book uh i think it's a pretty
interesting theory the caliph it's
interesting because it's not national
it's like this
it's own entity i don't know much about
it i just know that the head of the
caliphate is not necessarily the head of
the country yeah and so so is that they
would say the nation well the nation of
islam was a specific thing right that
was like a an organization that was
created yeah yeah but then you also have
then you have the church that comes down
right so like when you go into african
nations you'll see like the uh the white
jesus on the wall like i i i bury my
grandma i think it was last year in
jamaica and it was just hilarious to see
a whole black congregation and then them
have like a picture of white jesus on
the wall and all i just see is like
colonization
but i think uh
nations first ruled with religion and i
think you know after that economy
evolved and their the new religion is
something else now that's crazy to me
though because a lot of cultures have
their own ethnic
image of jesus like they're yeah we talk
about a lot there's japanese jesus
really yeah yeah honest dope yeah and uh
um we've we've had sheamus on talking
about it too where he's just like yeah
of course every culture views him as
like you know as them or whatever and
there's like no issue there or whatever
and interestingly uh apparitions of the
virgin mary are
often
different based on the culture
so
our lady of guadalupe appeared
their ethnicity in their cultural garb
but much different from
our lady of lourdes for instance or
fatima okay
um that's why i'm like i don't i don't
see it you know we see these memes all
the time from the left and they're like
here's what jesus really looked like and
it's like a sephardic like that's not
the point obviously there's no
description of what jesus looks like in
the bible because that wasn't the point
of him being thought it was daniel 7
verse 9 or daniel 9 verse 7. i could be
wrong yeah i said he who was six foot
five with bulging muscles and blonde
hair just he looked like jason mamoa
yeah from the from the from wait so
there's literally you say there is a
description of him but you were
mentioned yeah not to my knowledge is it
i mean i could see that that would be
intentional if he had like dark skin and
they're like we need to empower the
roman patriarchy and we need to
disempower the jews let's make people i
think this guy's a white guy i disagree
i think if they wanted to control you if
the idea was about control you would
need to convince the people he's of you
so yes the idea would be to make a
picture of a japanese jesus to make a
picture of an arabic jesus or a white
jesus so that those people would be like
oh yeah they're like me
so they gave no description or i want to
hear what you were saying what was it
called the the section where you thought
there was a description of jesus oh yeah
i said daniel 7 verse 9 of daniel 9
verse 7 i'm no biblical god i could be
completely off but
uh that that just popped in my mind
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 p.m
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there
you